hello mrs hill
hello mr bryce how does that feel mrs
hill
i it feels awesome it feels amazing
yes very very uh
you know what i'm just at peace like i'm
married i'm happy
and all is well and i love love love
saying
husband it's like my new favorite word
for 20 20.
oh excuse me i gotta call you back
that's my husband calling
not the only name change we're also at
lake
bailey on the hill now you caught that
you caught that yes we had to combine it
because i wanted
you know mike to feel included you know
what i mean he's my husband
we'll get into you and mike in a little
bit in the journey to
becoming the hills but i want to take it
back to just
this season season 13 a very different
kind of season of housewives
you know this whole 2020 has just been
about change everything's different so
the show is different you know for a
moment it just felt like the world
stopped
and my family and i were home
quarantined in los angeles
afraid to go outside but after the
george floyd murder we couldn't take it
anymore we had to be a part
of the
we got movement lot of work to do i
think it worked out great you know we're
doing
the best that we can do under the
circumstances like everyone else
he still created a good show i was in
such a different place and
my number one focus honestly was trying
to
get through this wedding you know in the
middle of a pandemic and
you know and then not even that making
sure mike and i
actually still wanted to marry each
other to be in quarantine together for
so long
we are going to watch you and mike
navigate the challenges of
sticking to this 10 10 20 date and the
moving pieces of
throwing a wedding and a pandemic and
there's kind of a hint in the trailer
that this
tested your relationship a little bit if
i can't have it might
then we can pull over and get married
now
[Music]
our relationship was definitely
tested because we agreed to
marry each other we didn't agree to go
to prison with each other
just have to be around each other 24 7.
breakfast lunch dinner morning noon
night
that's a lot that's a lot for any call
so yes we were definitely
tested we were definitely tested and
if there was any doubt in my mind if i
wanted to be with mike hill
i know now because i have spent a lot of
quality time with this man
let's address the elephant in the room
or the elephant in the trailer
stripper gate
[Music]
i really want to turn up for real
[Music]
turn off the camera
will fans get answers about what did or
did not go down at your bachelorette
party this season
will they get answers well
i mean i'm happy to give you my answer
yeah do you have answers give me
something my personal answer is
we all had a great time obviously some
more than others
you know i will say that
you know this is no judgment son this is
no judgment zone
everybody's grown everybody can do what
they want so i was
all in trust me to just have an amazing
amazing time and this was a surprise for
me i didn't even know i was having a
historic party
we saw you we see you in in a harness
all tied up in the trailer we know you
were there to have a good time
that was just like a segment my first
time being in the sex week
and uh i had that sex week i was going
to use it on my wedding night actually
but we were too tired we didn't have sex
on our on our wedding night like we were
exhausted
we just wanted to like take a hot shower
put on our little matching robes and
just relax
like but anyway um
you know what you guys will hopefully
get some kind of closure i can't speak
too much on
uh i was you know front and center for
the actual bachelorette party it was
some of the after parties that i was not
involved in
where you know some of these uh
allegations
have been you know brought to the
forefront so
hopefully so hopefully so the trailer
shows
kenya kind of stirring the pot here
bringing this conversation to the table
i'm hearing sex noises coming from a
bedroom
[Applause]
it wasn't a sex party
who said that how messy does this get
gets a little messy kenya's arm should
be very tired
from stirring that butt she stirred
certain stairs
she had to switch arms like she
definitely was trying to get to the
bottom of it for sure but
you know again this is a group where
anything happens in the group we talk
about it you know
honestly if you don't want to talk about
it don't do it in a group
that's what i can tell you so from your
perspective you've got closure on the
situation anything you needed out of it
you feel like you have the answers
oh i i i got all the clothes i could
ever want i
had a great time i was very entertained
uh again candy can throw one hell of a
bachelorette party that is for sure you
didn't use a sex swing
on the wedding night but have you used
it since i haven't used it yet but we we
are going to now we're saying
now i think i'm going to drag it to the
maldives to our honeymoon next year
okay okay tsa is going to open that
suitcase and go what the hell
i know like i keep like the sex wing is
packed and ready to go
drew is a friend of mine that smoothed
my leg hey
i bring the flavor to atlanta we've got
a new girl in the group this year
drew sedora yes what should we know
about drew heading into this season
okay you guys will definitely get to see
drew a little further down in in the
season but
just know it's gonna be worth the wait
she comes in
you know she's a breath of fresh air and
she's just cool she's a cool ass chick
and she just jumps right in and uh she
has a lot to say
she definitely doesn't take any any crap
from anyone
i was going to say she's got a that line
in the trailer don't
call me i'm from chicago [ __ ] we have
fun with that a lot in the season
it's like i'm like i'm from alabama
it's like i'm from the hamptons
no no but uh no there's a great addition
to the show and i think that the fans
will
um definitely resonate with her if you
had to compare her to a housewife we
already know
is there any comparison to make she kind
of reminded me
a little bit of kim feels in a way
because she has all that like
you know that child acting thing going
on she's been
you know acting for a long time um she's
been
you know you know she's had a career for
years
so you'll get like some little splashes
of kim a little bit but like a little
feistier kim
you've dropped a few hints that some
people are not getting along so
who do we need to be keeping our eye on
who do we need are there two people who
are
locked in any sort of feud this season
that we need to pay close attention to
well i'll just say probably
toward the middle to the end of the
season
you know the dynamic definitely kind of
changes with the
friendships on the show but we still got
three more weeks to go
and a lot can happen in three weeks but
i don't even know what's gonna happen at
this point
all i know is you know i'm usually
trying to be the peacemaker but it like
came back and bit me in the
ass a couple times right follow me once
for me hello happy ass right over here
like bailey and just be married
and let these grown women deal with
their own relationships
could the one over here went over here
could that be like a porsche kenya
situation
because that's kind of what we're seeing
out in the in the blocks
gotta wait and see okay we do know that
production
on the show shut down for a couple weeks
so when the cameras can go back up
what's the vibe like is it are we in the
middle of a feud
are do we have issues to resolve what
are these last couple
weeks or days of filming what are they
going to look like i hope
you know we do need to get to a finale
which would include all of us
so hopefully we'll be in a good enough
place that we can all be there for that
um i i hope that
we will be in a place of respect and
peace at that time
like i'm not saying everyone's gonna be
all buddy buddy at that point
but at least we can be in the same room
and we can just kind of look back over
the season and reflect on
how at the end of the day whatever
stupid arguments we have how blessed we
are
you know i'm looking forward to it i'm
looking forward to it
if you had to sum up this season with
one word what is your word for season 13
grateful grateful we all are just
grateful
i think all the ladies i can speak for
them on this are just grateful
that we still had a job this season that
we were still able to actually
you know film a film a tv show
and be safe and be as healthy as we
could
and still pull off what seems to be a
very entertaining
season that part